(orchestral music)
(sneezing)
- There she goes again.
- Did she just bark?
- Yeah, she's been doing in all week.
Just out of nowhere.
- So what do you?
- Well I bark right back.
It's like you want to play this
game, I invented this game.
(sneezing)
(barking)
- Nice, you know what
I've been doing lately that's really fun?
- I have about eight years of experience.
(barking)
Yes, yes, I actually interned
for a graphic design company in college.
(barking)
Yes, yes in college yes.
And I think I have all
the necessary skills
(barking)
to do well in your company.
Yes, Tuesday would be great, thank you.
- Sounds like a real win win.
- How's your love life Molly?
- Oh, I don't even want to hear about it.
- Well, I've almost bumped into
this guy Roger like a couple of times now
but we keep missing each other.
(car starting)
Oh, hey, I'm Molly and
you are walking away.
I just was to get up close so I
can get a good sniff or something.
- Food's here.
- Someone say food?
- Ah, yes!
- Oh look at this thing!
- Yeah!
- Hey Molly, Molly,
it's me, Roger, from the dog park.
She doesn't even know I exist.